más
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24
soy herminia fernández comenzamos
el sistema de salud francés se presenta
a menudo como un ejemplo por la calidad
del tratamiento y la universalidad de la
cobertura sin embargo existen algunas
disparidades en todo el país entre ellas
una grave escasez de médicos en ciertas
áreas que limita seriamente el acceso a
la atención un fenómeno que los
franceses llaman de ciertos médicos son
zonas en las que no hay suficientes
médicos en proporción de la población el
gobierno decidió aumentar la cantidad de
estudiantes admitidos en la facultad de
medicina pero tomara años antes de que
los médicos estén formados según
estimaciones esta medida tardará casi
una década en dar sus frutos en la
siguiente historia las reporteras de
france 24
pauline godard y claire pakhalina
cuentan cómo es vivir y trabajar en un
desierto médico a continuación la
historia
[Música]
y
desde esta mañana no he podido contestar
52 llamadas telefónicas si pueden ser
personas que llaman varias veces pero es
muy frustrante decir que hay personas
que no logran contactarnos pero estamos
a tope
este es el doctor hole hace parte de los
doce médicos generales jubilados que
ejercen en este centro de salud la falta
de médicos era tal en la ciudad de la
vall que decidieron volver a ejercer
cada uno trabaja un día a la semana
felizmente ahora y jubilados que quieren
continuar trabajando un poco porque no
sé cómo haría la gente es lo que dije en
la farmacia si no tengo nada como hago y
suspende todos los tratamientos y es
todo
estamos en el departamento de mayenne
tercer desierto médico de francia
aquí hay 65 médicos generales para
100.000 habitantes contra 89 en promedio
en el hexágono los médicos se encuentran
más bien en el sur donde la densidad
puede alcanzar 125 por 100.000
habitantes
para encontrar médicos aquí es un
problema he recorrido todos los médicos
que he podido aaron sanver bond serie la
vall imposible y usted donde vive en
poblet a cuántos kilómetros está de aquí
18 kilómetros
el doctor e gol adhirió de inmediato al
proyecto fue elaborado en especial con
la alcaldía de la vall en el consejo
departamental de mañana a sus 71 años
mencionan las razones por las que dijo
si
es el hecho de decirse que aún somos
capaces de hacer algo
tenemos un oficio que amamos y da gusto
seguir ejerciéndolo siempre digo somos
como unos drogadictos de la medicina y
pues la segunda razón es que vamos a
servir a los demás
actualmente 4 mil 400 pacientes cuentan
con un médico tratante gracias a ellos
pero esto que debía ser temporal se está
instalando a largo plazo el centro de
salud existe desde hace 5 años
los médicos jubilados y uno residente
consultan diariamente
hola me llamo timo tipo home soy
residente del doctor harold voy a
empezar la consulta se unirá a nosotros
al final que los trae por aquí tiene
fiebre verdad sí desde ayer en la mañana
da el se siente aliviada por haber
podido encontrar una cita para su hija
hace seis meses se instaló en la vall y
no ha podido conseguir un médico
tratante
la primera vez tuve que llamar a una
quincena de consultorios está claro que
es un problema uno se dice que en una
gran ciudad como el aval debería
encontrar un médico porque no se trata
de una pequeña ciudad joven pero no es
un problema
para mí había que hablar en la
televisión nunca pensé que no podríamos
encontrar médicos así
a médicos jubilados para los cuales es
esencial formar a la nueva generación
el contacto con los jóvenes nos permite
garantizar la continuidad del ejercicio
de la medicina general a nosotros nos
aportan jóvenes simpáticos un buen
ambiente y pues ellos aportan un poco de
cosas nuevas y nosotros les aportamos
nuestra experiencia
encontrar un médico general sigue siendo
un rompecabezas para muchas ciudades
aquí en el este de francia en el
departamento o hay 69 por 100.000
habitantes
no lleves susan cuenta con cuatro uno de
ellos se instaló recientemente pero aún
estamos lejos de lo que se necesita es
por ello que la ciudad decidió abrir
hace tres años una sala de telecos y
taxi mostramos
el verde
el paciente es atendido formación la
enfermera
ella se ocupa del pre examen
ella asiste luego al médico que se
encuentra en otra ciudad del
departamento
si los pacientes son acompañados porque
hay muchos que me dicen pero como el
médico podrá escuchar mi corazón mis
pulmones y creo que les da tranquilidad
que yo esté aquí porque puedo guiarlos y
ayudo al médico
al principio no confiaba mucho porque no
creía que todo estaba conectado creía
que uno decía lo que el niño tenía y se
basaban solo en los síntomas sin ver
realmente pero viendo la garganta todo
está conectado entonces da tranquilidad
como solución de socorro es perfecta
prefiero ver al médico pero la niña
necesitaba medicamentos de inmediato
entonces está perfecto normalmente todo
debería evolucionar bien gracias buena
tarde señora winston gracias igualmente
el otro lado de la pantalla los doctores
de vilar y vudú antiguo surgen tistas en
el hospital público de trier partieron
de una observación cada vez más gente
venía a urgencias porque no contaba con
un médico con el fin de descongestionar
crearon este consultorio medicina el
único en francia reconocido por el
registro de médicos
tenemos agradecimientos frecuentes pero
también tenemos la amargura de los
pacientes de tener que ser atendidos así
a distancia por un médico porque lo que
preferían es tener un médico presente y
nosotros les explicamos que estamos aquí
temporalmente mientras se encuentra en
un médico tratante y mientras alguien
esté interesado en venir al territorio
mientras haya alguien que pueda asistir
los estás en las consultas tienen una
especificidad en el lugar exclusivamente
en la región gran está en 70 salas
dedicadas a ello
vamos a construir con el médico general
con el consultorio de enfermería con el
farmacéutico con servicios
con este pequeño ecosistema del
territorio del pueblo a escala de la
ciudad o la comunidad se construye un
verdadero proyecto médico que
escribiremos juntos en el que se
describen todos los procesos de acceso a
esta tele consulta la cita las horas de
apertura quien asistirá al paciente
sustentación los desiertos médicos no
afectan las otras zonas rurales a las
puertas de parís en santander ni
encontrar a un médico es casi misión
imposible
aquí la densidad de médico general es de
59 por 100.000 habitantes una de las
peores cifras del país
el y can durante estos dos últimos años
seis jubilaciones no fueron reemplazadas
como esta señora thriller
dentro de poco el doctor julián se
jubilará hace varios años que se retrasa
su retiro pero esta vez está decidido
colgará el estetoscopio el 30 de junio
de 2022 habrá atendido a los habitantes
de libre y durante 43 años
se cumplen
así que tienen que jubilarse
y vendrá alguien más
estamos buscando
eso la preocupa
sí un poco porque ahora hay muchos
doctores que ya no quieren aprender a
domicilio y como tengo dificultades para
caminar
cuando hay un doctor que viene a
domicilio es más práctico
[Música]
y envejecer tiene su dificultad
usted es joven señor ya quisiera
92 años este año
césar
el problema no cambiará en tan poco
tiempo sabemos con la historia del
números clausus puesto en marcha por el
señor juppé no se contrataron
suficientes médicos
durante más de 40 años el números
clausus limitó la cantidad de
estudiantes admitidos en segundo año de
medicina paralelamente la población
francesa siguió creciendo así como la
solicitud de atención médica y por lo
tanto de médicos
los que se jubilaron durante los últimos
años han sido muy poco reemplazados
en aquella época luchamos diciendo que
era un error es todo el número es klaus
es inventado por tecnócratas y siento
que había mucho consumo medio que
suprimieron médicos como sea si se
suprimiera la enfermedad y nos hemos
dado cuenta que así no son las cosas
desde el 2021 el números clausus se
terminó por primera vez el año pasado
una cantidad récord de estudiantes pasó
a segundo año lo que está empezando a
generar los problemas a las facultades
en cualquier forma habrá que ser
paciente antes de ver los beneficios de
ello se necesitan nueve años para formar
a un médico general
hay pocos médicos que se establecen
ahora es un desierto médico
el hecho de que el doctor rolando pueda
seguir atendiéndolos me angustia
la gente me dice el doctor sigue
trabajando ya van tres veces que dicen
que se jubilan y lo aplazó
mi mejor forma de no angustiarme es
seguir trabajando pero será necesario
algún día 74 años tengo que dejarle mi
lugar a otro
usted está en búsqueda activa
por ahora no lo logro en la ciudad es
infructuoso
en 10 años sánchez en y perdió cerca del
25 por ciento de los médicos generales
yo me imaginaba como médico general
teniendo en cuenta los problemas
demográficos médicos
debes instalarte en una zona en la que
te necesiten tenía sentido estar en
pantín y pues fue en pantin
hace un año surgió la casa de la salud o
field el
proyecto de paul newman
ella también una joven médico general no
trabajar solos poder hablar con otros
colegas ayudarse contar con una oferta
adicional de cuidado ese era su deseo
aquí cuatro médicos generales trabajan
tiempo completo
ortodoncistas una partera un psiquiatra
un psicólogo
da la impresión de estar en casa yo creo
que uno se siente bien también por estar
con médicos jóvenes que escuchan mucho
la ventaja de la casa de la salud es que
imaginemos que mis 45 lapsos de citas de
urgencia están completos aquí somos
cuatro médicos hay reemplazantes
etcétera puedo decir pueden tener aaron
estoy a tope hoy ha representado trabajo
volvimos a hacer todo esto al mismo
tiempo nos decimos estamos en casa
estamos bien es como una familia es como
una pequeña casa médica pero familiar
pero tuvieron que esforzarse para
concretar este proyecto su costo asombra
más de un millón trescientos mil euros
los dos médicos pudieron contar con
cerca de 500 mil euros de ayudas de la
región y de la alcaldía con un
acompañamiento importante el de la unión
regional de profesionales de la salud
son cosas para las cuales a uno no lo
forman en la facultad no se enseña en
medicina pero no la parte arquitectura
el aspecto contable financiero el
aspecto jurídico montar los expedientes
lo administrativos
[Música]
un médico en el territorio es
conocimiento social a través farmacias
médicos población comercios etcétera
hay que motivar eso
nosotros queremos que usted encuentre su
felicidad instalándose quedándose en la
región porque hay necesidad
desde el 2018 la cps acompañó 29
proyectos similares ensanche de mí pero
tal como en muchas ciudades estas casas
de la salud son rápidamente víctimas de
su éxito
abrimos hace un año yo en todo caso
empiezo a plantear la necesidad de
limitar los nuevos porque los que ya
aceptamos nos llaman la atención sobre
las citas los plazos empiezan a volverse
largos estamos reflexionando sobre la
organización
aumento de la cantidad de asistentes
médicos aumento de las ayudas obligación
de instalación para los médicos las
propuestas de la pasada campaña
presidencial fueron numerosas para
luchar contra los desiertos médicos el
reelecto presidente de manuel mayo
tendrá que dar solución a este flagelo
que golpea a francia de cualquier forma
este será uno de sus principales
desafíos
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]